Back on the road and back on the bike.
It's Bolsonaro's favorite way of campaigning.
Driving through Juiz de Fora, he paraded for his fans.
This is a small city that has huge significance for Bolsonaro.
It was here four years ago, he was stabbed at a rally,...
...a defining moment in the previous campaign...
...and a moment he alluded to at today's event,...
...saying he'd been born again.
It was here they tried to stop us in 2018.
I thank the hand of God who saved me.
He wanted me to be president...
...and Brazil is doing so well.
It's a rich country, robbed by the left who was in power.
His rival, Lula, chose to kick off his campaign at a car factory,...
...staying true to his political roots...
...as a union leader and metal worker in Sao Paulo.
You made me the best president Brazil ever had.
It's a noisy start to the campaign and says a lot about what's to come.
Two men on either end of the political spectrum.
Two men who conjure up both adoration and hatred among people here,...
...and we'll see that play out in the coming weeks.